hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar quality assurance and quality
control monitoring in liquid
chromatography Mass spectometry service
I'm Susie Valdez of labots and I will be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labots and brought to you by Waters
Corporation to learn more visit them at
Waters
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
might have during this presentation to
do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation you may also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation this webinar
is educational and thus offers free
continuing education credits I'd now
like to to welcome our speaker Dr
Richard
kincom from Department of chemical
pathology in the Chinese University of
Hong Kong Dr K obtained his PhD degree
from the Chinese University of Hong Kong
in
2011 and was responsible for managing
proteomics Laboratories in different
institutions until
2013 and since 2014 he was a staff in
charge of
pharmacokinetics and
pharmacodynamics laboratory providing
OnDemand bi analytical service in
support of clinical
trials currently he holds a position as
scientific officer in the department of
chemical pathology at Prince of Wales
hospital and he is responsible for
providing lcms based clinical proteomic
service with emphasis on inherited
metabolic disease
investigation Dr K welcome you may now
begin your
presentation right so uh thanks for the
kind introduction and my name is Richard
cim I'm from the Chinese University of
Hong Kong and in this presentation today
I'm going to share some of our
experience in the QA and QC monitoring
in lcms
analysis so uh first of course some of
our introduction to our hospital that is
the Prince of Wales Hospital in Hong
Kong so uh we are we we were established
in 1984 and we are serving a population
of about 1.3 million and the specimen f
is uh quite not that large about 3,000
something per day and uh we have a bom
medical M Spectrum we unit station there
which is a equiped with about 10 lcmsms
both triple cord and top
instrument and we are covering quite a
lar wide scope of surface and uh in this
presentation uh we will talk about some
of our experience in the QA monitoring
using lcms so particularly we'll be uh
covering some of the uh items here that
is the UN ratio the monitoring of the
internal standard and material
commutability and also the
interpretation of the profiling
test
right so uh first of all what is so
special about lcms especially in the
clinical setting so in a certain sense
this a very expensive and fancy detector
and it provide a very specific
measurement of the analy now lcms is not
used mainly for the sensitivity no for
sensitivity measurement Eliza or other
imuno AET will provide much better
measurement but LMS the string for the
instrument is the specificity so the
risk of
force reference is quite low but it's
never zero right and lcms give us a lot
of information uh so the interpretation
must be done really
carefully now most of the essay provided
on lcms are laboratory develop the test
instead of the invidual diagnostic so uh
in if anything happen to your essay you
cannot blame the vendor because they
only provide you the instrument and the
labor is solely responsible for the
ldt now most of the test is done
manually on lcms and uh to is humans
right so uh the operator is one of the
variable that is inevitable we always
have to take into account the operator
including the training and also their
specialty so on lcms platform uh we
commonly measure some of the uh drugs or
steroids in the plasma or serum these
are the common analytes uh also there
are some uncommon analy encounter on
lcms like the uh incumbent steroid like
the oxidation product or metabolite like
garoni or metabolite of vitamin D and
also some of the uncommon TDM drugs or
measurement like the free drugs
measurement uh these are not commonly
found on the IM platform or invidual
diagnostic so uh these are the main area
that u a lot of the ldt are being
developed of course there are some
legendary analyze that is only possible
for to be measured by lcms like the
structural isomer of some of the sugar
uh protein variant isoforms or even some
degradation products now this requires a
very specific measurement to avoid CA
reactivity in the EM
essay but when we go down the list uh
these analyz are more likely to be done
by lcas but uh of course it would be
much more difficult for quality
assurance because of the lack of the
standard and also the test become much
more complex
now here's a very simplified fish fish
diagram showing all the parameters that
may affect the measurement in the
clinical mpect from pre-analytical
measurements to the LC separation data
review and
Reporting so uh First We Take a look at
the sample preparation now most of the
step are done manually so the staff
training and petting and whatsoever pay
a big role in the quality of the LC M sa
uh since the test are ldt so the retion
and material quality must be uh must be
really uh secured to to ensure a quality
result also uh the LC Mark may have some
unique quality control policy so that we
will cover later
on LC separation again consumable pay
break par in this in this uh particular
parameters uh Pak shape and retention
time are also some of the things that we
need to look
out Ms detection uh signal intensity and
stability of course is very important uh
within batch or between batch uh
corotation of the detection that is a
use of iron ratio and also the Matrix
effects are also some of the importance
parameters now data review is one of the
most critical part in the entire
workflow because uh we need to know what
parameters are important and what are
not because the LCR is giving us a lot
of the parameters so uh we need to
sharify some of the importance of these
parameters in order to have a very
efficient uh quality assurance
policy all right so here is a very
typical uh data review for a
quantitative aay in this case we are
measuring the dial coding uh of course
the in the analysis we have a set of
cators in this here here is eight level
calibrators two set of QC and then some
of the unknown
sample now in this table it shows a lot
of the LG Mass parameters but usually uh
the things we look at is the iron ratio
the is area sorry the internal Center
area so we have to have a very steady is
area and then the concentration of the
samples and uh in in the following few
slides I'll share some of our experience
in dealing with some of these
particularly the internal standard and
also the IR ratio of the
detection okay for triple qu aay the we
are measuring the analy based on the q1
and Q3 M Chanel so the we select the
parents on the q1 and then select the
daughter on the Q3 so the uh parent
daughter pair is called the mrm
Channel and for measurement of an anite
usually we will be measuring to
mrm so the iron ratio is the signal
ratio between the two mrm
transition that is basically the
measurement of the two different
fragments from the same parents molecule
so uh if the molecule is uh correct the
detection is specific then the IR ratio
should be quite consistent across
different uh
samples but one thing we need to we need
to look out is that the iron ratio is a
concentration dependent so when we go
down the concentration and when the
concentration approach the eror oq of
course the iron Rao will fluctuate
a and also the different an may have the
different behavior in the iron ratio
fluctuations now in this slid this some
of the iron rati
distribution for some different
molecules like vitamin D3 methine small
pepti like and gensin one and also
steroid like
andin and and at the first look of
course we see a lot of different
distribution in the IR ratio some of
them are quite precise uh like the
vitamin
D3 and metan nephrine as well and for
the peptide like ensin one the
distribution is a little bit wider and
andin we measure the concentration at a
very low nanom or even Pico range so the
iron ratio fluctuates quite a lot and
follow quite a normal distribution
pattern so uh when we devise a cut off
or acceptance criteria for iron ratio we
need to consider different behavior in
different molecules and out of range
does not always means interference uh we
have to interpret the IR ratio uh
according to the concentration or some
Anal specific parameters but it is a
very still very useful parameters in
some
cases and here is our experience in the
measurement of the testosterone and dial
coding in the
serum and what we encounter is an
incompatible e materials and we identify
this problem based on the IR racial
analysis so the measurement of the
testosterone and DHT is quite simple
actually we do a simple liquid liquid
extraction discard theum protein reum
dry the extract and then do the lcas
analysis and then the result obtained is
shown here the first uh row is the uh
internal standard the isotop label the
internal card DHT and the second and
third row are the different mrm channel
for the d uh D
testosterone now for standard and
patient serum the peak detection is
quite discrete so the uh the behavior of
the serum and stand are quite similar
and then for the EA material and we kind
of see a uh D testosterone Peak here at
the same retention time as the internal
standard so well maybe this is the
target we are looking for but then when
we look at the iron ratio we see that
the the the E material is quite
different to that of the patient and
standard while the peak detection at
that out is uh is quite
reliable so uh the AR ratio suggest that
there might be some interfering
substance in the ekp
materials so uh we in the alcaline wash
step in our sample preparation try and
try to remove some of this interference
and actually this is just a .1% ammonium
hydroxide followed by the another round
of liquid liquid
extraction so after the alkaline wash
you can see the equili material the iron
ratio kind of uh return to normal
compared to the patient and standard and
then without an alkaline wash we can see
that the peak detected here is actually
not the D
testosterone and then after the alkaline
was and based on the uh correct iron
ratio in the UK material The observed
the concentration is actually much lower
when we uh skip out the aqualine was so
uh the UN Rao in this case help us to
identify the
need and avoid a for detection of the
Dio
testosterone so uh another uh another
topics we would like to discuss is the
uh sem Paris and how the SLE preparation
procedure will affect the internal
Center
fluctuation so uh some of the common uh
Matrix in Clinical Laboratory is the
blood or
urine now blood uh some of some people
may consider blood to be a more dirty or
nasty Matrix compared to urine because
the blood is more viscous and contain a
lot of protein but actually in terms of
the chemistry the blood is a fair
predictable Matrix because uh all the
blood are more or less similar so when
we take out a blood sample from your
Clinical Laboratory you can almost tell
that it contain is about 150 MIM
something sorts and about 20 30 gram per
liter of protein or or whatsoever so the
chemical composition of the blood is
more predictable and compared to urine
the composition is actually is quite uh
fluctuate and can be quite different
between different patients so these are
much more unpredictable Matrix and also
give us a lot of problem problem in the
quality assurance in the urine
test now here are some of the uh common
SLE preparation strategy in the kinal M
Arena ranging from protein precipitation
to liquid liquid extraction and then
solid phas
extraction now uh the complexity will uh
will increase when we go down the list
right because in the protein
precipitation actually you are not
extracting anything you're just making a
dilution liquid liquid extraction uh
you're involving a more step so you are
extracting some of the unwanted
component and the extract is a little
bit cleaner and the Sol effect
extraction is just another pre- column
before you do the LC M
analysis but the extract will be much
cleaner compared to the other two
approaches but then uh while the extract
is cleaner you're also introducing a lot
of variation during your sample
preparation and that may affect the the
uh internal standard and other
parameters
right the internal standard is kind of
an internal calibration because you
introduce the internal standard at the
start of your sample prep and it will
correct any uncertainty associated with
the entire
worklow and most of the case we use a sa
isotop label analy so it has the same
chemical properties but a different Mass
property so the importance of the
internal standard is that uh we are
relying on the is signal for calibration
and the internal standard has a has a
reciprocal relationship with the
concentration so if there is an
artifactual drop of 20% of your internal
Center signal then the obser the
concentration will increase by
25% so the main uh dilemma we are facing
in clinical MP is how to know if the
internal Center is working properly so
where is the line between a normal
fluctuation of your internal Center and
an internal Center failure like uh
someone uh mistakenly piped the wrong
volume of internal Center in a in the
particular samples or the Matrix effect
suppress the iron ratio uh suppress the
iron internal Center signal to the point
that it affects the concentration
measurement and some of the variation
include a human era or Ms detectors or
sample matrices also play a role in this
uh internal standard
fluctuations so uh we took a look at our
own data and see how the internal
standard fluctuate between different
batches of analysis so what you're
seeing here is the measurement of the
cyos sporing a in Hope blood uh simp
very simple protein precipitation with
Organic solvant and then do a triple
cord measurement so uh you can see the
internal standard the Precision is quite
good within each patch most of them are
within 10% or even
5% and even we take overall in prision
the CV is only 6% 6% or something so the
prision is quite good and mainly because
the SLE preparation is also very simple
right and then we also look at the some
of the uh internal standard Precision of
course Different analy Serum mun protein
sample also by protein precipitation
analysis in position also quite good at
about 10% something vitamin D is is a
small molecule but then we use a liquid
extion so the ration was a little bit
larger in Precision it's about
15% Ur metan nephin again very complex
uine matrices coupled with an online
solid face extraction so you can imagine
there are a lot of very
in the sample preparation Pro procedure
so the incision is can be up to 70% in
the internal
standard but even though the uh
fluctuation of internal standard can be
quite large in different test but the
problem is how we can tell uh that
fluctuation is normal or is it working
properly so one thing is to compare the
Imp imposition in the sample and your
QC so cyle point a the internal stand
internal standard in position are quite
similar in QC in your sample ASF fun
vitamin D and also meanin the QC and
Sample are also very
similar so then we can check whether the
QC uh is uh within range or out of range
to tell whether the internal Center
fluctuation is is is acceptable or
not and then another way is to look at
the internal Center Trend doing the
analysis within patch so what you're
seeing here is the internal Center Trend
in different test across six different
batches so uh actually the even though
the fluctuation can be quite drastic the
the trend within each batch should be
quite consistent and then we need to
take out some of the sample that
fluctuate quite a little bit for example
for a fun you can see some samples uh
they deviate from the trend drastically
so we took that out and do the repeat
analysis and found that oh this was
really an internal standard failure in
some of this sample
and causing a forcely high measurement
in the
concentration okay so uh we also look at
the long-term measurement uncertainty in
different essays so even though the is
inisis is quite large in some of the
tests the long-term measurement
uncertainties is actually quite good
actually most of them are below 8% or
something and we have the same
performance in the eqa program so in
this way uh we can tell that the
internal standard decision uh they're
doing their job right the internal
Center fluctuate to correct for any
variation in your test even though some
of them fluctuate at about 60 or 70% uh
C
percentage that uh procedure or this
practice Ries solely on the
commutability of your QC material that
is the fluctuation of is in your QC
should be able to uh remic that of the
samples so this uh brings us to the next
topic that is the commutability
so the definition of commutability is
basically that the material of your QC
or GQ should has the same behavior as
your patient sample in different assays
so in this way your QC is monitoring the
aay uh correctly just like your
samples okay so uh some of the source of
the QC materials can be from a
commercial Source there are Mo mostly
available for common analy but uh they
may not be designed for LC M essay
mainly because they are designed for
imem essay or other platform so we at
this uh in this Cas we already have some
computability issues uh homemade
material uh we can do the spiking uh
experiment to generate some of the uh QC
at our descided
concentration but for some of the
endogenous analy like the methanphines
or urine Coro it would be quite
difficult to obtain a suitable matrices
or patient samples to do the
spiking sample re analysis uh actually
we are just picking out some of the old
sample and then reanalyzing them to see
if the accuracy or the result is
consistent kind of like the uh incor
sample reanalysis so of course they are
totally Matrix match they must be
computable but uh we have the problem of
the value assignment and how to
establish a ass
criteria and the last result is to use
the E material uh actually it's not it's
not feasible
because checking your performance uh
using the E material but that should be
an external quality assurance material
so you're checking yourself in this
case Okay so uh we share two experience
in the Comm commutability of materials
and both of them are involved with the
IUN aay so uh first is the uh
observation of the oxidizer form in the
EQ material
so uh we found out that the rcpa the e e
material actually has a very large
amount of the oxidized igf1 so the
oxidizer form of f fun has a different M
charge value in our essay because of the
addition of the 16
Delon now uh here are some of the M
Spectrum in our QC the patient samples
and also the rcpa
materials so the large Pak here is aun
while the minor CL of PE uh is the
oxidizer form of the a one so uh the
oxidizer form is actually not observed
in the qcn sample and it's only observed
in the substantial level sual level in
the E
material so uh what we have is here is
that the correlation of the gkp material
between our platform and other imuno
acid are quite different to that of the
samples so the native F fun the level is
about uh 80% of that of the amino acid
because amuno acid cannot differentiate
between native form and oxidizer form
but lcms can differentiate between them
so uh in order to have a good
correlation between the two platform we
have to combine the measurement of the
Native hyren and then the oxidized hyren
together and then we can get a good
correlation between the two
platform but that observation is only
made in the E material because the
oxidizer form was not observed in the
patients so the in this uh this this is
an example of the
incompatible non-commutable EQ
material and in order to have a uh
realistic interpretation we have to take
into account of the alizer
form okay so the second one is the
calibrator commutability and the value
assignment so uh in order to do a
proficiency testing for our a fund
measurement
we are sending out some of the patient
samples to another appro for correlation
and we observe that that the cycle one
and two correlation has a very
sustainable High
bias so uh we there are two proposed
action one is the correlation of the
cators and the second one is the
continue correlation of patient sample
for another cycle to see if this is Du
to due to the imposition problem in both
the
Laboratories so uh first we send out a
set of the col at to them and then do
the
reers and then again uh we see we saw
that the correlation of calibrators is
quite different to that of the patient
samples so uh in another laboratory the
uh low bias is more uh more pronounced
in the calibrators but not that much for
the patient
samples now uh if we adjust our
calibrators based on the correlation
value it will actually show a more drust
low bias for the patient
samples sorry the high bias because you
assigning a lower value for the
calibrators which does not reflect that
of the patient samples so uh the work C
we identify is that the calibrators we
use are actually an artificial Matrix
that is a 4% BSA in PPS with the proteas
inhibitor so it is not entirely Matrix
match with the patient samples so in
this case the uh the calibrators is not
commutable between the two
laboratory so uh when we do the value
assignment based on the correlation
experiment we need to be very careful
because we may uh introduce another
problem to the patient samples instead
of correcting some of the
bias okay so uh Now we move on to the
last last Topic in this presentation
that is the small molecule profiling in
the clinical mass
spectrometry now the strength of the uh
lcms is that the LC can separate a lot
of the small molecule along the
chromatographic gradient and then
the very specific measurement
individually so this a very uh powerful
technique for the quantitative
measurement like the plasma amino acid
or serum ASA cins or Fair long chain
fatty acids because uh now most of the
test are related to IGM that is a
pediatric patient and the the sample
volume for Pediatric patient is actually
very small so uh we not we want to Maxim
maximize the ELD of the test in a small
sample so uh the lcms is uh is the most
preferable option because uh we can
measure a lot of things in this small
amount of the uh BR
volume now uh small mo profing may also
be applied semi- quantitatively like for
the measurement of the urine organic
acids now in this typical uh test
platform we are commonly measuring like
more than 30 or 40 analy in a single run
like uh we are measuring more than 35
amines in a single
run and it's kind of the move mov into
the Ring of the metabolomics analysis
now one thing about this uh metabolic
analysis is that uh most of them rely on
the pattern recognition and not just a
single number so unlike uh the the r
function or Li function right we are not
looking at individual single number we
are looking at the variation or the
level of the different Amino as a
whole and this pattern recognition is
used to differentiate between normal and
disease now in the traditional QC rules
we are looking like the multi Ru like
22s or 13s but uh if we apply that rule
to the profiling test that will be a
problem because if we are assume a KC
setable criteria is plus or minus 2 SD
that is about
95% uh
95% and all analy behave independently
then if we measure simultaneously 35
anal like in run analytical
run then actually the probability of
observing one hour control event in one
QC sample is not 5% it's actually
31% and observing two events is about
27% so the probability of actually a
false alarm is much higher compared to a
single analine
measurement so uh our laboratory is
doing quite a large number of this test
and usually uh in each analytical one
we'll usually observe one or two anal
out of the 2sd criteria so the next
question is shall we stick with the
traditional Westar QC rule or multi
rules okay so uh these very general
multi rules most of us are quite
familiar with this right 13s or 22s r4s
or TX rules they are used to uh
interpret your QC uh initial analytical
run now when we go back to the original
paper in wcard the wcard multi rule is
not a really go standard or all
laboratory should follow right the
multiv rule is to provide a simple data
analysis and display while the control
charts and the main idea is to reduce
the level of force rejection while
improving the capability of detecting
analytical errors so kind of like the
reference interal interpretation is a
balance between sensitivity and
specificity of your
essay now when we go to the uh the some
of the standard or eqa provider of the
uh IM analysis so we can see that uh
most of them has some of has some policy
or suggestion on your QC rules but they
also highlights that the result of your
the the goal of your analytical
measurement is to to make a correct
diagnosis or correct interpretation of
your result regardless of the location
where you perform the test so at the end
is the uh interpretation that matters
but not individual
values now when we look at some of the
common profiling test uh we can we can
compare the measurement and uncertainty
of individual analy and what we are
looking for in the clinical
interpretation so for most of the uh
analy measurement and certainty we can
keep both of them below 10% including
amino acid and very long-ter fatty acid
but then when we look at the individual
analy in this uh in different test for
example the finalin right we are what we
measuring why we are measuring finalin
is because we want to pick out the PKU
but in the PKU presentation the level is
about two to three fold of that of the
upper reference in up noral of the
reference in the and there are also
other parameters that we can take into
account like the fin link to tyrosin
ratio AO solution uh the the dinosis of
msud again to the F higher than the
upper limit of the refen Copo together
with some of the elevation of franching
amino acid right cine again almost 20
fold higher than the ri and with cross
elevation of ponia right as c c ctin at
least to to F4 right so on and so on so
uh in the in the imem uh dinos also
so uh most of the analy we are looking
at are not just one or two unit higher
than the referenc level but at least two
to three F higher so in that case it's
5% or 7% measurement uncertainty or when
we apply that to a 2sd rule does it
really introduce a lot of risk to the
patient inter uh result
interpretation now uh in the clinicaly
now we are talking more and more about
risk management so we are basically
categorizing the risk uh based on the
frequency of occurrence and the uh and
the criticality of the
event and of course in imem most of them
might be critical or catastrophic if we
miss some of
them but then uh we also need to take
into account different analy and how
frequent they uh they will give us an
out control
event so uh here some of a a very
simplified table showing some of the
analy so uh this for reference only
right I'm not suggesting that you should
strictly follow right but uh most of the
analy they are they're not critical and
for critical one I I I totally agree
that they they have should have a more
rigorous control in the in the QC and QA
procedure like Alo isolution finin or C3
and C5 s
trity some of the anal also are quite
serious like branching amino acid
adenine or multiple longchain fatty acid
exocar glycine right but uh you may
relax a little bit because uh the
disease they are associated also has
other biochemical markers that may help
in the
differentiation now uh other analyze uh
the criticalities a little bit minor
like the individual long train Astin or
or other Amino like Hine orotic AET
because the isolated increase or
decrease in this analy are not specific
to the M so the risk of missing some of
the dinosis is quite low even though
they analy show a out of control
event so in this case you can stratify
the uh the analy and device an
individual QA and QC procedure to
minimize the force
rejection okay so uh this is uh my last
slide in this presentation so uh lcms
fundamentally is quite similar to a
chemistry analyzer just just a fancy
detector but the interpretation of the
read out should be a little bit more uh
careful in general it's not an indidual
diagnostic test so a human input is
essential right you we cannot avoid
human input or device a totally uh
logical uh QC policy in the lcmr you
need to have some improvement input in
the
interpretation so quality assurance is
also more than just a QC chart we have a
we need to have an understanding of the
platform the capability as well as the
limitation of what it can or cannot
do for the multivar analysis like the
profiling test so we are facing hundreds
of measurement and while all analyes are
equal in the profiling test but some
analy are more equal than others right
compromise has to be made if we want to
ensure the efficiency while maintaining
the specificity of the
assay so the ultimate goal here is to
minimize the patient risk and force
alarm while maintaining the efficiency
of your uh
platform so uh that's the end of my
presentation so uh thanks very much for
your
attention and thank you Dr KH for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar and if you have any questions
you want to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far far left of your screen and
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time
for so it looks like we already have
some great questions coming in from our
audience let's take a look our first
question what are the most important
parameters that you feel when it comes
to qaqc monitoring of
lcms
analyses all right so uh when we come to
lgms uh analysis what I look for mainly
is the uh internal Center area and also
the uh retention time but uh in terms of
these two parameters what I'm looking
for is mainly the consistency within
each batch of the analysis so I won't
expect to see one or two sample uh
suddenly for example the retention time
or internal Center area fluctuate
suddenly jump to another RT or is not
consistent with the entire patch or not
consistent with the QC so uh between
patch uh the consistency is less of a
concern but uh within the single batch
of analysis I'll expect these two
parameters to be uh quite
consistent and for the profiling test uh
what I'll be looking for is mainly the
just I mentioned previously some of the
more critical analyze and also the
overall interpretation so uh for the
profiling test in the in the when we do
the QA policy so uh we we will also
introduce some of the QC but uh the QC
is not mainly just to monitor the
individual concentration of analy but
more on the interpretation like for
example in the when we add the QC to our
let's say Ur organis analysis so it
would be best if we include one or two
positive uh uh positive uh patient
samples for example patient with the
propionic acidemia or C accidia type one
and see if in that analysis we can still
pick out some of the critical an and
make a correct interpretation so uh
these are this I think is the most
important parameters in the LC Mar
analysis in clinical
setting thank you so much Dr K and Dr K
how does your laboratory review and
authorize patient
results well uh in our laboratory uh
when the technical staff will mainly do
the basic review on all the prim and
Analysis for example
the and also the basic uh lcms with and
then the interpretation of the
authorization of the patient result is
usually done by uh specialist like
pathologist and also uh LMS scientist uh
because the interpretation is mainly we
have to take into account a clinical
background of the patient and as a
scientist we are to advise the Peres the
limitation and our lcas platform the
their capability and limitation so uh
the basic review is done by technical St
and then the authorization of the
patient result and report will be done
by prist and
specialist thank you so much now what
eqa schemes do your lab participate
in well for uh General uh quantitative
essay uh we mainly participate in rcpa
eqa from Australia and uh for some of
the IM test of course we join the uh the
EA scheme because they provide very
comprehensive uh e scheme for un Oran
asset and other real test like transfer
G form analysis right so uh these are
the main e scheme of our
laboratory thank you so much and we have
one more question coming in Dr K what is
the differences versus other platforms
when it comes to qaqc
well uh when compared to other platforms
uh the lcms is actually much more
complex in terms of the read out so uh
the main difference we face when we do
lcmr in clinical setting is the
information overload actually for
example in a simple uh concentration
measurement analysis the the read out of
analysis will include tons of parameters
for individual uh patient samples and
also the KC so we need to uh have a very
comprehensive understanding of the
platform to see which one is important
and which one is not and compared to
other uh ivd platform like the automated
analyzer usually the read out is much
more simple so the you can check the
basic parameters but they they won't
generate a lot of data or parameters for
you to manually look through each one of
them so I think this a most important
difference between these two platforms
so uh for lcms SAA so uh we really need
to have a very soil scientific
understanding of the platform in order
to make a corre
policy Dr K I want to thank you for your
presentation today do you have any final
comments you'd like to provide for our
audience before we
go well uh for the audience uh I think
LZ M uh right in clinical lab we talking
about Eminem right MB and molecular so
MB is also getting attraction in The
Clinical Laboratory so uh I what I hope
that in the future there will be a more
and more Innovative test or platform in
lcms that may benefit the patient
especially the the specificity provided
by LCR is really powerful in the
clinical settings so uh hopefully we are
moving forward to a to a uh better
platform and more advanced technology
that may help the clinical diagnosis of
the
patients Dr K I want to thank you again
for your important research and your
time today I'd also like to thank
labroots and our sponsor Waters
Corporation for underwriting today's
educational webcast and before we go I
want to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
OnDemand period will be addressed by our
speaker via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration and
this webcast can be viewed on demand
Labs will alert you via email when it's
available a for replay we encourage you
to share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time take care everyone and
bye-bye byebye